hello again everyone the next game I'm
about to show is well one of my absolute
favorites played by Michael Tao this was
played in 1967 so it championship and it
was played the vocal teacher Ganesha is
white and the nickel towel is black and
let's hit this game at West lady for
Knight to f6 c4 c5 towel place the Ben
Oni defense d v e6 Knight to c3 e takes
on b5 C 1025 d6 Knight to f3 g 6e for
Bishop to g7 Bishop to e2 black castles
this is all standard theory
white castles towel plays rook to e8
nights - D - nice - a six I just like to
mention that capturing this night with a
bishop - double black spawns isn't good
for white because this bishop is a good
piece and well capturing here will lead
to a Banco type structure which is OK
for black so white goes rook to e1 top
ways Knight to d7 a4 and now b6 and if
you're an only player you should
remember this b6 move because I know
that black wants to play here a 6 and b5
but if you play a 6 then white will play
a a 5 and you'll no longer be able to
play v6 for the rest of the game so
after a 4 you should remember this and
play b6 and only then a 6 and b5
if white allows it of course so white
plays Queen to c2 and this is the most
important moment of the game this is a
where you can really see how far tells
imagination goes it's also that when
white plays Queen c2 if you left this
rook on a1 undefended and although this
rook is so far into White's camp and
none of the black pieces are actually
able to attack it tau find a way so that
plays nice to g4 and here gurgenson
knows that he's playing against McHale
and he doesn't really want any
complications it's okay for whites to
capture the night here with Bishop
captures energy for but what doesn't
want to part with this bishop so why
thought that the towels idea is after h3
just ring maneuver tonight's the e5 but
this is why I named this video don't
play h3 against nickel towel here you'll
see what style has in mind Tom plays
Knight captures on f2 and here you have
captured the knight or you're just worse
so King captures on f2 and now Queen to
h4 and this is where you can see that
towels idea of this undefended rookin II
one comes to place now the White King
can go to g1 where it's safe he has to
go to f1 to defend this rook anyone so
King to f1 and now some place Bishop to
d4 here tall is threatening checkmate on
f2 and there's really not a lot of ways
you can stop this the only move White
has to stop this checkmate is to play
nice to d1 and here it's like
sacrificing the knight on f2 wasn't
enough of a shock for your Ganesha here
top waste quintic Queen takes on h3 and
this is a very very hard to play for
white if the queen is captured is then
Bishop takes h3 checkmate you see how
those two bishops or slicing the
position nicely and if you don't capture
the Queen
well Palace present Queen to h1
checkmate so white has to stop this
somehow white plays Bishop to f3 and the
tile plays Queen th two nights the e3 f5
that wants to break open the position
Knight to c4 f takes on e4 Bishop takes
on e4 and now Bishop to a6 and now this
knight is pinned the since the king is
on f1 top with a Gorgon is a place
visual to f3 rook the e5 this knight is
pinned like we said so the rook cannot
be captured Rho 2 a 3 and now rook to e8
doubling up Bishop to d2 and now Knight
captures and defy
and this night can be captured with the
knife because if you play nice captures
and defies then simply go into h1 is
checkmate
so after Knight to d5 White's right the
bishop takes at five
but here Tao plays rook captures on f5
and on d5 and again the route cannot be
captured because of the mace of the
Queen on h1 so white rice King ke to and
here at our place fish up to e3 rook
captures on e3 and our Bishop captures
on c4 and in this position wife resigned
if you capture the bishop because it's
checked then simply Queen captures on g2
check King to d1 and Queen captures on
d2 this is checkmate and the other
variation is even more fun because if
you don't capture the bishop and play
something like for example King to d1
tal would play rook captures only three
row captures any 320 g1 checking the y
king and after rook to e1 play queen to
f2 and in this position black has no
defense against this Bishop to b3 move
if the Queen captures the bishop then
Queen to d2 is checkmate so any move
white plays if he even has a move for
example g3 then Bishop to b3 is coming
painting the Queen and if the Queen
moves then
Queen to d2 is checkmate so yeah this is
like I said one of my all-time favorite
games played by Michael towel and now on
to the rules of the quiz I have planned
for Saturday the quiz will be formed
with the 60 questions and you will have
one minute for each of those questions
if the question is answered sooner then
we're going to the next question before
one minute has passed and at the end of
the well the trivia the one who has the
most points will be the winner and will
be awarded the chess set I still haven't
decided as to what chess set it will be
able to post this tomorrow so if there
will be a tie at the end then we will
an elimination round with a couple of
more questions until well the winner is
chosen so the tournament will be held at
Saturday at 9 p.m. but that's 9 p.m.
considering my time zone in the
description below I will put a timer so
you can all see the exact time it will
be played considering your time zone
well from wherever you're playing and I
will also schedule a live stream so you
can also pre-register for the tournament
although no pre-registration is required
you can simply just join the stream and
before the tournament starts you can
join and even if the tournament has
started you can also join but then your
chances of winning will be well somewhat
lesser so I think that's about it thank
you for watching I hope you enjoyed this
game Michael Tao played in great style
and I will see you soon
so farewell
[Music]